financial and political chaos a prime
minister refusing to quit but the UK
media aren't alone in saying time is up
for Liz truss
her sacking of her Chancellor and friend
Quasi quateng on Friday and her dismal
performance in a news conference
afterwards failed to calm the markets
now it rests with the new occupant at
the Chancellor's office at number 11
Downing Street Jeremy Hunt to turn
things around on his first morning in
office he was critical of what truss has
done so far it was a mistake to cut the
top rate of tax at a period when we're
asking everyone to make sacrifices and
it was a mistake to fly blind and not to
back up the economic plans that were
announced with an independent forecast
from the office for Budget
responsibility while hunt says he
supports growing the economy he's
talking of increasing some taxes the
only Cuts will be on some of the
spending
ministers and party grandis would
normally look to number 10 for Solutions
and tactics not now it's number 11
Jeremy Hunt the fourth Chancellor in a
matter of a hundred days he's got a
strong background and it would appear he
has a mandate to rewrite large parts of
important government policy
some in the conservative party say truss
has become a lame duck prime minister
because she's appointed hunt he's the
dominant figure in in the government I
mean you could imagine can't you if you
were asked to take on that role the
concessions that you would demand in in
order to do that and it would have to be
you know your control over Economic
Policy over Personnel over key
committees whatever the conservative
party does it can't afford to trigger an
election one new poll suggests it has
less than 20 support the opposition
labor party is rallying its members
whatever they say now
whatever they do
it boils down to one argument for them
it's party first country second and
that's unforgivable the change this
country needs is a labor government
this trust is that the prime minister's
country residence for the weekend
battling to save her job Jeremy Hunt
spent most of Saturday with his treasury
teams working on a formula he might be
able to tame the markets but may not
save the Prime Minister Andrew Simmons
Al Jazeera London